could lucifer lose his immortality
will ella uncover the devil's secret and
who will end up ruler of hell by the end
of the series
yupikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video we're investigating 16 incredible
yet possible theories and predictions
that could change
everything for the final two seasons of
lucifer we'll be talking spoilers so
take care if you're not caught up this
is gonna be good
yeah i'll have some of that a big moment
in the first part of season five comes
when lucifer regains his invulnerability
around chloe dan shoots the devil with
chloe nearby but lucifer emerges
unscathed and rather pleased with the
outcome
even offering himself up as a devil
shield to the detective
but there was an important moment
earlier in season 5 that suggests this
development could
go into reverse with lucifer choosing to
forsake his invulnerability entirely to
become a mortal being
in the noir episode lilith gives up her
immortality breathing into her ring that
she gives lucifer and explains an
insight she's gleaned from her thousands
of years living among humans
they all think they want to live forever
but they already have something so much
more precious
it's knowing there's an end that's what
makes the rest of it count
that's what connects them to one another
likewise in season three we heard kane
aka marcus pierce compare immortality to
hell
i've walked this earth for thousands of
years i have seen everything i have done
everything
that's almost like you're in hell yeah
now that lucifer and chloe are a couple
what could be worse for lucifer than
watching chloe eventually die
and then continuing to live for an
eternity without her back in 1946 when
lilith asked lucifer if he'd ever made
an emotional connection with a human
lucy scoffed at the notion would take a
literal miracle for me to want something
like that i'm fairly certain my father's
not handing those out anymore but of
course that did happen
so could lucifer decide to follow
lilith's example and give up his own
immortality so that he and chloe can
grow old together
or alternatively could chloe become
immortal from the ring
but then what about trixie another
outcome that could solve all that is
lucifer being forgiven for his rebellion
and being able to return to the silver
city when he wishes
so that when chloe eventually dies they
can be together there as well
in season five while lucy returns to
earth to deal with michael amena deal
takes his place in hell to keep the
demons in check but to lucifer's
surprise in the fifth episode he
discovers amena deals back with linda
and when lucy demands to know why he's
left hell unguarded
meladil explains there i was wandering
the corridors of hell
when i heard a voice a voice that i
never expected to hear in hell
according to a menadil that voice was
god who told him that hell no longer
needed a warden
when i first saw this scene it struck me
as odd given that having a proper ruler
watching over the underworld was such an
important plot point for season four
and given that a menadil says he thought
that it was strange to hear god's voice
in hell i wonder whether michael sneaked
into hell and impersonated god's voice
to fool a menadiel into leaving the
underworld without a ruler again
this could be yet another trick michael
has pulled to make lucy look
bad in front of their father we know
michael can easily switch accents and we
already saw him performing this trick on
dan when he called his phone pretending
to be lucifer so that dan would see
lucy's devil face
now that dan's discovered lucifer's true
identity out of the main cast
only ella is still unaware that lucy is
literally the devil
however i expect that will change when
she finally finds out by the end of
season 5.
and given ella's religious beliefs i
think this moment could be an even
bigger shock for her than it was for
chloe or dan
or linda ella says she grew up among
criminals and dirtbags but that when she
turned to god it set her on a better
path
so her reaction when she finds out she's
been living alongside the devil as his
friend in la will be very interesting
of course this isn't the first time
ella's unwittingly befriended a
celestial as her ghost friend
ray ray was actually lucy's angel sister
asriel
ella also has this dark side to her
which the show played up a lot more in
season five with her attraction to what
she calls bad guys
and then there was pete the seemingly
nice guy secret serial killer who also
said he saw darkness in ella
and there was a very interesting moment
in the diablo scene when ella finds a
prop weapon
supposed to be the only blade that can
kill the devil and then proceeds to
attack lucifer with the rubber blade
hey yeah hmm sorry that seemed a lot
funnier in my head i'm sure
now obviously the moment is played for
laughs here but could it also be a
little bit of foreshadowing for ella
trying to attack the devil when she
discovers him on earth
by the end of the series i expect we
will find someone in charge of hell who
isn't
lucifer as i think god will at some
point recognize that he's done enough to
serve out his punishment
the most likely candidate at this point
is michael because once his dastardly
schemes against lucifer are revealed to
god he would surely get banished from
heaven and perhaps sent to the
underworld to rule in lucifer's place
a possible though less obvious option
for new ruler of hell would be maize she
was already keen to go back to hell in
season one but lucifer insisted they
stay in la and so she decided to find a
purpose for herself as a bounty hunter
and at the start of season five maze is
mad at lucy for going down to hell
without her
the technical problem with maize taking
over down under is that she's a demon so
theoretically it would break this rule
hell was built so that no demon could
take control of the throne only a
celestial could rule but given
everything that happens in the show it's
not impossible for this rule to be
broken if the writers wanted to make it
work
something that could play into this is
mei's discovering that she isn't an
ordinary demon and does actually have a
soul in fact there was a hint to this in
the mr and mrs mazakin smith episode of
season three when you kill you lose a
piece of your soul
i get the feeling you understand that
sorry no soul here
it's not what i see my other theory is
that maize will resolve her existential
angst via the ring her mother lilith
gave lucifer and i go into detail about
that in my ending explained video
maze is such a fan favourite that i
expect she'll eventually find her
soulmate by the end of the series
at the moment eve seems like the best
option for mays as they already formed a
connection in season four
and if maize is also in charge of hell
then i can definitely see eve
joining her there as she enjoyed helping
lucy punish sinners when she was with
him on earth
and then kinley also suggested she could
be queen of hell with lucifer so why not
with maize instead
a character who might not make it out of
the series alive is dan though he could
still get a happy ending of sorts
reuniting with charlotte in heaven
in the first episode of season five we
see that despite his attempts to be
positive dan is still struggling to get
over charlotte's death from season three
i think dan will get a special moment to
shine before the end of the series
perhaps playing a crucial part in
defeating michael as lucifer saw an
unusual strength in dan where he was
wielding the powerful divine weapon
asriel's blade in season two you're
fighting the blade
which indicates a strength i didn't know
you heard this michael was able to send
a mena deal into a fierce spiral that
made his time manipulation powers go
crazy could it be possible that
michael's fear mojo was also to blame
for that mysterious moment
in season 4 when lucifer's mojo powers
went haywire
at the time lucifer's self-hatred and
fear that chloe couldn't accept him for
who he truly was
meant he began transforming physically
into his full devil form but a side
effect was that everyone in luck
started to tell him what they desired
even though he wasn't asking them
michael seems to like lurking in the
shadows hidden from view and in season 5
there was that moment where he vanishes
into the crowd at lux
indeed lucifer himself also commented
that michael enjoys hiding himself away
i've passed his prologue he's probably
hidden himself off somewhere to laugh
about the mess he's made
so perhaps michael has been around
longer than we know causing havoc and
triggering events like lucifer's mojo
going wrong in season
4. after all he did tell lucifer that
he's basically been manipulating him
since the dawn of time
something which is still a mystery about
michael is the reason for his sloppy
shoulder as lucifer calls it
i expect the backstory to this will be
revealed in the second part of season
five and it may be an injury he suffered
during lucy's rebellion against god
if lucifer does have anything to do with
it then of course it will be yet another
of michael's grievances towards his
brother
the moment many deckerstar fans waited
five seasons for
finally happened when lucifer and chloe
did the deed and discovered that hell
didn't freeze over but what are the
chances that chloe could now be pregnant
with lucifer's child
it's already happened to amena deal and
linda on the show and lucifer even joked
about it when chloe found herself naked
in lucifer's bed in the first season
i'm pretty sure we made rosemary's baby
i don't think this will be a main plot
point as it could feel like too much of
a repeat of charlie's storyline and it's
not something i'm especially keen to see
myself however there are fans who would
like this so it could be something that
happens at the very end of the series as
a kind of epilogue if lucifer and chloe
settle down together
speaking of which is entirely possible
we'll see the devilish couple tie the
knot before the show's over
the diablo episode is packed with many
comical meta moments as lucifer and
chloe investigate a murder on a tv show
inspired by their own partnership
during the case lucifer chances upon a
script for an unaired episode called
diablo in space
and when he and dan act out the script
they read out the line
a devil in the heavens which makes me
wonder if we can look forward to a
lucifer episode that's actually set in
heaven
and i go into lots more detail about
that hilarious episode including all the
little easter eggs and details in my
season 5
things you missed video tap the card
here or follow the link in the video
description
perhaps the upcoming musical episode
titled bloody celestial karaoke jam will
end up taking place in heaven
where we'll get to meet another of
lucifer's siblings castile
when remy arrived on earth in season
four a menadil made reference to
castile's love of song so it feels like
this will be the appropriate episode to
introduce the character
what brings you to earth need a break
from castiel's singing and wouldn't it
also be great if we got to see azrael
again especially as charlene was just
fantastic in that role in season three
the ending of season five part one
seemingly reveals that charlie isn't a
half angel as we'd assumed because he
got sick with a fever and a cold
however i think there's something else
going on here which caused charlie's
illness
the clue is in the episode just before
when a menadiel is talking to linda
about how content he is being a father
and looking after charlie
linder agrees but then tells him to
enjoy the moment while it lasts and then
says that if they do a good job as
parents
charlie will need them less and less
every day a melody
seems somewhat perturbed by this
realization and given we know that
michael was trying to trigger his fears
could a mena deal of
accidentally made charlie ill michael's
fear mojo was powerful enough to cause
amena deals time
control powers to spiral out of control
so what else could they have affected
however my alternate theory on the cause
of charlie's illness is that it's
related to amenities misdiagnosis of
chlamydia by doctor in season three and
i explain all that in my season five
part one ending video
so what do you think about these
theories for the show's final two
seasons and do you have any theories of
your
own on how the series will end leave
your thoughts in the comments below
tap left to watch my next lucifer video
and season 5 playlist
or tap right for another video you're
sure to like and if you enjoyed this a
thumbs up and a share are hugely
appreciated thanks for watching and see
you next time yupikai movie lovers